an amazing conversation with the man who
by any measure has led an amazing life
at the very center of American culture
for decades
covid had an effect on his life and his
thoughts about it here's that part of
the conversation
did watching kovid and the medical
establishments response to covet over
two years change your view
I mean that was a piece of it that was a
piece of it what did you think of that I
mean well specifically I'm going to lean
into the the black condition just for
you know being a black person
you know we've been getting killed in
hospitals
for years Grandma Mom don't come out
you know we've been getting killed with
our food to start off with we've been
getting killed by police officers you
know every day we've been killing each
other
in the streets
every day you know I felt like the
people at the Gap knew about the school
shooting that uh Matthew McConaughey was
talking about before it even happened
it was so in synced the information and
then I heard about it on the radio
driving I was like am I in The Truman
Show right now
and I Tell Candace she's got to watch
the truma so you gotta you have to watch
what do you mean the people at the Gap
knew about the school shooting I think
in Uvalde Texas yeah I'm not saying that
they did but it felt so in sync
this idea of like this media rush over
the 78 specific Outlets
that influence
meanwhile so there's a coordinated
message I think that's what you said
yeah meanwhile
the
uh
there's the same amount of kids getting
killed in Chicago every week but there's
no coordinated message about that have I
reach Alex Jones territory yet no I
think you're telling the truth okay
and that's okay if you do
what I'm saying is like yeah they keep
on using the oh he's crazy he's crazy
thing
and it hurts my feelings
when people say that it hurts my
feelings that people can ask me
hey are you okay like especially like
just I got an ego
someone that's less successful than me
having the right to ask me about me like
they are a doctor
what you want me to put some ice on it
and put some ice on my brain it's gonna
fix it
you know everybody's got the solution yo
you put some ice on it do you know if
that work we wouldn't need hospitals we
just have like ice dens for everything
and stuff it's like
Grandma's got cancer put some ice on the
cancer
but you you know I'm like funnier than
comedians right like and I'm like but
you get that you get you get that a lot
people with the kind of faux sympathy
are you okay
yeah it's like
you know don't but you get that even as
a famous person oh go ahead you know go
before me this hey what do you want and
like it's hard for people to even listen
to you you know they're just so like oh
my God this is yay do you hear what he
said again and there's a lot of people
that have been put in my organization
where it's their job to not listen to me
in your own organization absolutely and
that kind of thing can drive you what
crazy yeah I I had um
uh my resolution this year was to only
talk to people who listened to me
shrink the number of people you talk to
not enough
bad enough because that's how they do
they send the bots in there's people
working here you know it's like
you have Prince had to constantly fire
people
I gotta constantly fire people it's just
all kind of people sitting around doing
nothing charging I had 530 Consultants
last year
for your businesses for my businesses I
didn't know we just hired some guys in
and you know this is the issue when you
hire atheists
I think that's illegal to say in
California but you know sue me
this is the issue you know because
God-fearing people
perform for an audience of one
at the end of the day we all know we
have to answer to God
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight